happy holidays this year we got you the
trailer you've requested the most for
some reason
after 42 volumes of comics 18 movies and
15 seasons of television one live-action
adaptation will ignore everything people
loved about the Dragon Ball franchise in
America's biggest insult to Japanese
culture since Hiroshima Dragonball
Evolution prepare for Fox's half-assed
attempt to cash in on their expiring
rights to Dragonball it's an adaptation
that steals from everything except the
source material featuring elements of
the matrix Lord of the Rings Twilight
and Last Airbender showcase track it's
the most basic of all the airbending
techniques oh come on
when the Sith Lord piccolo escapes his
ancient prison somehow Goku a student at
video game high school must find the
Dragon Balls before something about an
eclipse or else something about loser oh
the evil monkey werewolf it doesn't make
any sense
can I get a little help here we'll take
it from here honest trailer voice man
voice thanks guys I've totally lost all
right listen up Dragon Ball is the epic
saga a martial artist - wait that's Goku
well this is an outrage I never went to
school
also I don't think you're white I'm a
sighing he way it's about no ku here's
quest to collect all seven wish-granting
Dragon Balls before wha when did I get a
hot asian sidekick maybe this movie
isn't so bad I am 10 Roshi be vegetable
hahahahahahahaha my grandfather's dead
Oh nope it sucks
gonna walk away Goku is joined by his
best friend growling who should be
showing up in the movie any second now
second you're not in the movie dammit I
gotta be honest guys this still seems
pretty stupid but like the show is way
better I fly around on a magic cloud
by the shape-shifting man pig and open
three hundred year old man get laid
we sold yet not really but thanks for
trying you bet
bye bye honest trailer man voice man hey
my room uh power up for a movie that
doesn't just sound bad it looks bad as
the epic he attacks from the cartoons
are replaced with CGI hand farts
squirm as the awkward level goes over
9,000 in a movie full of long pauses
you're different I like different
terrible dialogue grandpa I'm so happy
to see you and Justin Chatwin 's
forehead babe
so gather up all your balls pivot for
the one wish that everyone can agree on
make this movie never exist story how
dare they make a movie about Kakarot and
not invite me
oh god not another one I am Vegeta
prince of us say oh my god is that the
beta male looks like a tiger with Down
syndrome
nevermind bullet dodged would you like
to do the honors
of course I will story Keiko TT's the
mask
the key-maker Crouching Tiger dead
career nobody's favorite Ghostbuster
mightyjoyoung and not Laura crong oh god
what a steaming pile Dragonball
Evolution so wait caki not wishes a guy
he just met back to life at the end of
the movie but he just lets the man who
raised him from birth stay dead and I
can dig that special thanks to team four
star and if you want to get us something
for Christmas be sure to click that
subscribe button
really we're doing this again fine
kamehameha it's over 9000
next time on Dragon Ball Z how man bears
does Bear Grylls grill
if Bear Grylls could grill bears
reindeers exsist
yes Virginia there is a Santa Claus
Merry Christmas and a Happy New Year